so put your hands together and give it
up for
rito
you're my lawyer a lawyer with a
corporate sponsorship
that's completely ridiculous league of
legal is sponsored by curiosity stream
and nebula get 26
off using the link in the description
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because today we are analyzing
idiocracy the movie that if memory
serves
is about the world's most average man
who is cryogenically frozen and then
wakes up hundreds of years later
after the world has gotten much much
dumber you want us to put
water on the crops yes water
like out the toilet which of course
implicates all kinds of
laws and regulations including i think a
trial
so it should be fun to compare real-life
laws with the laws of the fake future
after the world has
gone down the toilet what the [ __ ] god
damn shit's changed in a year
so without further ado let's dig in to
idiocracy
would you like another extra big ass
fries
i said i didn't get any thank you your
account has been charged your balance is
zero please come back when you can
afford to make a purchase
oh i'm sorry come on my shoes are
starving
this should help you calm down well i'm
sure most corporations would love to be
able to
gas uh their customers if they're uh
getting obstreparous like that i think
that that probably qualifies
as a battery battery itself doesn't have
to be the physical touching it can often
involve
offensive contact and if a regular
customer would not be okay with
being gassed in with some sort of
sedative i that probably qualifies
carl's jr of the of the future engaging
in some
welcome questionable carl's jr would you
like to try our
extra big ass taco now with more
this particular individual the unfit
mother me no no
okay this particular individual is
unscannable
so obviously uh luke wilson is not an
unfit mother but
i think this does raise the question of
when are the police actually allowed to
arrest you and under the fourth
amendment police are authorized to make
an arrest so long as they have
probable cause and in legalese we say
probable cause must be based on
specific articulable facts taken
together with rational inferences from
those other facts so here
you cannot make a reasonable inference
from a kiosk
an automated kiosk a robot effectively
saying that luke wilson
obviously not an unfit mother is an
unfit mother here
not surprisingly these police do not
have probable cause
to arrest luke wilson but by the same
token most courts say that if police
mistakenly arrest someone due to a
misidentification
then there's no constitutional violation
so long as that mistake was reasonable
so
it's a question here whether the police
were acting reasonably or not
uh probably not and as to the question
of whether police can just
tackle someone during an arrest uh
police are generally allowed to use
reasonable force to
restrain and arrest someone assuming
that they have
uh probable cause to be able to arrest
someone in the first place but i for one
find it completely unrealistic that any
police officers in the united states
would ever use
unreasonable force to detain and then
take someone into custody see that just
that doesn't happen
wait a second there's the other part
from the army experiment there was girl
she was from the same experience
joe was arrested for not paying his
hospital bill
okay so joe is arrested uh
obviously in a situation that's
completely uh unreasonable then he's in
the back of the squad car and they mace
him for asking questions
police when they have someone in custody
and they have someone that is resisting
arrest or attacking an officer
are allowed to increase the force that
they use
to counter the resistance but it's an
unreasonable use of force to
mace someone who is handcuffed and is
not threatening the officers but again
this is completely unrealistic we never
see police officers just
indiscriminately
using mace or pepper spray against
people who are not resisting arrest
or just going about their day exercising
their first amendment rights to
freedom of expression now since y'all
say you ain't got no money we have
proprietarily obtained for you on them
court appointed lawyers okay so that
is absolutely a real thing there are
court appointed lawyers they're called
public defenders there was actually a
1963 case called gideon versus
wainwright
that establish the constitutional right
to people who are accused of
criminal acts who can't afford an
attorney because it would be such an
injustice to deny them an attorney to
represent them
in this criminal trial then the state
can and should provide them with a
public defender to at least provide some
defense though we've seen in a lot of
different situations where some states
seemingly on purpose
will underfund the public defender's
office we've seen allegations of that in
louisiana where
often the district attorney gets
millions of dollars per year but the
public defender's office will get
nothing and they're not able to provide
the defense that the
accused are constitutionally entitled to
so put your hands together and give it
up for
rito
you're my lawyer a lawyer with a
corporate sponsorship
that's completely ridiculous league of
legal is sponsored by curiosity stream
and nebula
i mean here the whole courtroom has
various corporate logos completely
plastered over everything there's a
flag that has a corporate logo it
appears to be funding the criminal
justice system
often people talk about judge judy or
the tv shows that you see
that have an actual real judge it's
actually private arbitration where the
contestants agree
to be bound by the decision of judge
judy or whoever is is playing the judge
but it's still not a real courtroom it
would be completely ridiculous for
the actual state courtroom to have
corporate sponsorship and you can
imagine that
there'd be all kinds of reasons why you
wouldn't want private enterprise to
interfere with
uh the criminal justice system itself
prosecutor
why you think you've done it okay number
one your honor
just look at them
i assume that this is some sort of
opening statement here
you're not allowed to actually make an
argument in opening statements that's a
common misconception
uh you're supposed to say what the
evidence is going to show really seems
like they're not going to enter any
evidence it just seems like they're
going to
go with whatever the prosecutor says
here we've got all this
like evidence of how like this guy
didn't even pay at the hospital and i
heard that he doesn't even have his
tattoos
okay i stand corrected he is now saying
that he has evidence that's going to
show
something he skipped out on some sort of
hospital bill uh why that would be a
criminal issue i'm
not entirely sure and then he lapses
into
hearsay saying that he heard that he
doesn't have the
scandal tattoo no idea why
this would be the place where he'd rely
on hearsay evidence because he could
just look
at the wrist of the accused and find out
whether he
actually has the tattoo or not though as
we've talked a lot about on this channel
the exceptions to the hearsay rule
really swallow the hearsay rule in
general so that
usually if you have hearsay evidence you
can find a way to get it admissible into
court
the way he has phrased it here it might
be the rare exception where that hearsay
is not coming in because there's
lots of other kinds of evidence that
would be better it seems like in the
future
uh the courts are are not great i know
and i'm all you got to be me but check
this out man
joe should be like guilty peace
honestly that is not the worst opening
statement i've ever heard in my life
what are you objectifying on it's too
late to object
okay um
your honor i object
that this guy also broke my apartment to
[ __ ]
yeah what and you know what else i
object
that he's not gonna have any money to
pay me after he pays back all the money
stole from the hospital
okay lots going on here lot's wrong
first of all
if the public defender is a material
witness to the case
then they'd be conflicted out there's no
way that they could represent
this particular individual and of course
they'd probably be called to the stand
if they're actually ever
going to ask for evidence to be
submitted on top of that it is a big
problem
in both the criminal and civil justice
system that a lot of people
aren't able to afford the verdicts that
are entered against them that's being
called
judgment proof the judgment is
effectively invalid because they'll
never be able to pay the things that
they
stole or are liable to somebody for
that's a big issue but as a public
defender
you're not allowed to raise that as a
defense in the case itself i mean
there's already a lot of stuff here that
would qualify for a mistrial
what are we doing here okay sir we're
engaged in procuring your tattoo
welcome to the identity processing
program of america
please insert your forearm into the
forearm receptacle
thank you okay it should come as a
surprise to absolutely no one that the
government can't force you to
get an id though there are plenty of
situations where a
government actor can force you to
produce an identification that you
already have if you
have it on you though forcing you to get
a tattoo on your body
almost certainly unconstitutional though
there are
certain instances where a government can
force you to undergo certain bodily
modifications if it's in the interest of
health
safety welfare or the morals of society
and that sounds
far-fetched and it sounds draconian but
we saw an example of that very recently
when
we've been talking about vaccines
because in the 1905 case of jacobson
versus massachusetts the supreme court
ruled 72
that a mandatory vaccination law was a
legitimate exercise of state power to
protect public health and safety
in terms of the spectrum of what's
allowable between a vaccination
and a forced tattoo maybe there's a big
chasm between those two and
maybe they're not that far away it sort
of depends on the justification
and the exercise and the reason for the
exercise of the state's police power
uh yeah i don't see you in here so
you're gonna have to uh
stay in prison could you check again
because i was
you know i was definitely in prison okay
i got sat on my face and everything
maybe check those files back there
[Music]
[Music]
okay so the question here is can you use
deadly force against a convict who is
attempting to
escape and the answer generally is yes
states like florida give officers the
legal right to use any force they
believe reasonably necessary to prevent
the escape
of an arrested person and not a single
state requires
the use of deadly force as a last resort
now the american bar association has
urged states to allow deadly force only
when necessary to prevent and escape
by a prisoner when the person is about
to leave the enclosed area
without authorization and the aba also
recommends the officer shout a verbal
warning before attempting to shoot or
use deadly force but generally that's
not required
oh yeah it's time you're going to get us
a carter
[Applause]
warning costco has detected a dangerous
fugitive in aisle 16702
okay so the question here is
can the state conduct basically
warrantless surveillance of
of everyone while that is certainly a
constitutional controversy
under section 702 of fisa that does
allow the nsa to collect billions of
electronic communications including
those
of americans and to use those
communications in a criminal
investigation
all without a warrant and it seems that
that authorization is alive and well in
the world of idiocracy because that's
how joe has been caught
is it a slippery slope will we continue
down the path towards uh
unauthorized or warrantless surveillance
will we ever roll that back
i guess i guess we'll find out fun look
if you guys are taking me back to that
jail just go ahead and shoot me because
there's no way
oh
it's so unconstitutional but at the same
time it's it's really really funny so
we've already talked about
it being uh improper to mace
someone who is under police custody
who's not really posing any threat and
fighting back
and repeated macings would similarly be
unconstitutional though there's a big
issue in this country of
not being able to get compensation from
police officers who
are going outside of the constitutional
bounds
in theory at least the way that you
would get compensation as someone who
was a victim of police brutality is you
would file a section 1983 claim
under federal law against the police
department but
there are all kinds of reasons including
qualified immunity as to why those
police officers can often
escape any kind of responsibility so it
certainly seems like the doctrine of
qualified immunity is alive and well in
the idiocracy world because i doubt
these police officers are going to face
any kind of liability for the repeated
macing of their captive
the results of joe's iq test had caught
the attention
of the highest levels of government okay
wait a minute
i'm the smartest guy in the world it
says who the iq test you took in prison
you got the highest score in history
brought to you by carl's jr
yeah dumbass you've been smarter than
president camacho that's how comey's
making you secretary interior
okay so who are you i'm the secretary of
energy
i won a contest got to be a cabinet
member
what a wildly unqualified cabinet member
in the white house
that would that would never happen i'm
the secretary of state
brought to you by carl's jr why do you
keep saying that cause they pay me every
time i do
it's a really good way to make money
you're so smart why don't you know that
corporate influence of a member of the
cabinet in the white house that would
that would never happen and that's the
secretary of education
it's kind of stupid for place president
camacho's stepbrother
still does a pretty good job man
straight up nepotism amongst the
advisors to the president
i can say that in the white house i work
with some phenomenal people
that would that would never happen
dwayne elizondo camacho
five-time ultimate smackdown champion
porn superstar and president of the
united states
had called a special summit a president
who used to be on professional wrestling
hey
[Applause]
a president who has sex with porn stars
i laid there and prayed for death is
this a documentary did this movie
predict the future what am i seeing
right now
president camacho stood before the world
and promised everyone that
joe would solve all their problems he
would not only
end the dust bowl and heal the economy
but he would cure acne and car sickness
as well
a president who doesn't know what
they're doing and makes vague promises
that they can't possibly deliver
i'll give him my word that would
that would never happen
he tried taking water from toilets but
its secretary not sure who finds himself
in the toilet now
and as history pulls down its pants and
prepares to lower
its ass on not shore's head it will be
daddy justice who will be crapping on
him this time
we now go live to violence channel
correspondent for micah davis
at the extreme court with highlights i
mean
this is completely unrealistic because
fox news appears to actually be
reporting the news that doesn't seem
realistic at all
thank you velveeta well it started off
boring and slow
with not sure trying to [ __ ]
everyone with a bunch of smart talk
blah blah blah you gotta believe me
that part of the trial sucked the
supreme court does not do trials
though uh interestingly the springboard
still does not allow uh cameras inside
so it would have to be an artist's
depiction uh it would have to be an
artist's depiction
to portray what's going on but then the
chief jay just
went off he said man whatever
i mean that's kind of awesome you have
to admit the guy's guilty as
we all know that and he sentences us to
one night of rehabilitation
i i don't even know anymore
[Music]
this guy just got his ass apart
yeah so it used to be back in the day
that if you wanted to
pardon someone there was an entire
department at the white house that was
responsible for
reviewing the file and making sure only
people who
deserved the pardons would receive them
if they made the request
though in recent days it appears that a
certain u.s president has completely
circumvented that process entirely and
just decided to pardon whoever they want
so
this actually surprisingly not
far-fetched
and so after serving a short term as
vice president
joe was elected the president of america
a former vice president who was elected
to become president of the united states
hasn't happened yet but maybe someday it
will
[Music]
okay now it's time to give idiocracy a
grade for legal realism
this 2006 movie posits a world where
lawyers have corporate sponsorships
where the police are going around
indiscriminately macing and pepper
spraying people who aren't resisting
arrest
it posits a white house that has filled
the advisors with people who are wildly
unqualified who got the job through
sheer nepotism a president who used to
be on professional wrestling and
had sex with porn stars and who cares
more about his personal image than
actually running the country
so obviously this movie is completely
unrealistic
for 2006 for 2020 i give it an a-plus
that's what i thought now we may be
devolving into an idiocracy but there's
still one place where you can get smart
thoughtful content it's called nebula
and it's where i put an extended cut of
this video
ad free with bloopers and i put in some
extra reactions about undercover cops
and the army getting friendly with a
character named upgrade
we're dealing with an army officer for
absolutely no reason whatsoever
getting the consent of a criminal pimp
here but
that's that's a phrase i never thought
i'd be saying because sometimes even
legal issues are too hot for youtube
because
youtube's algorithm can be really
capricious which is why my creator
friends and i teamed up to build our own
platform where
creators don't need to worry about
demonetization or the dreaded algorithm
it's called nebula and we're thrilled to
be partnering with curiosity stream
nebula is a place where creators can do
what they do best
create it's a place where we both house
our content ad-free and also experiment
with original content in new series
that probably wouldn't work on youtube
in fact if you liked this video then
you'll love what's on nebula because not
only are my videos ad free but
for almost all the videos i put up on
nebula they have an extended discussion
or bloopers or some extra content and
they also release early before the
youtube version does
nebula features lots of youtube's top
educationalist creators like
lindsey ellis thomas frank and charles
the coconut with his sidekick
patrick willems we also get to
collaborate in ways that wouldn't work
on youtube like tom scott's amazing game
show money
where he puts a bunch of famous
youtubers against each other in
psychological experiments where they can
work together or profit individually it
is ridiculously good so what does this
have to do with curiosity stream
well as the go-to source for the best
documentaries on the internet
they love educational content and
educational creators and we worked out a
deal where if you sign up for curiosity
stream with a link in the description
you'll also get a nebula subscription
for free
and to be clear that nebulous
subscription is not a trial it's free
for as long as you're a curiosity stream
member and for a limited time curiosity
stream is offering 26
off of all of their annual plans that's
less than 15
per year for both curiosity stream and
nebula and because i'm a lawyer i made
sure that 26
off is by contract the best deal you'll
find anywhere and since we've got to
stay inside anyway we might as well
watch curiosity streams awesome
documentaries or just watch tom scott
torture your favorite youtubers on
nebula so if you click on the link in
the description you'll get both
curiosity stream and nebula for 26 off
or you can go to curiositystream.com
legal eagle it's a great way to support
this channel and educational content
directly for just 14.79 per year
so just click on the link in the
description or go to curiositystream.com
legaleagle plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my grade for idiocracy did it
really predict the future
it really kind of seems like it leave
your objections in the comments and
check out this playlist over here with
all of my other reactions including
my reaction to my cousin vinnie and
suits and all the other
legal procedurals out there so click on
this playlist and i'll see you
in court